okay so I'm continuing with some insight
number nine I'm not sure how many of
these I'm gonna do is episode by reviews
I know the people who wanted me to see
this series are really digging this
you've made that clear in the comments
it's it's really little view wise which
normally I wouldn't care about I mean
I'm not a not a views chaser by nature
but I have stumbled into doing almost a
video no not almost a video a day lately
I don't know how the heck that happened
I'm literally wanting to talk about more
things than I can cover with a video a
day and I might have a hard time
justifying dedicating you know a day to
you know episodes of this show so I I'm
going I'm definitely gonna do episode by
episode reviews for the entirety of the
first series of it after that I'll
probably continue to watch it but after
that I'll probably either just stop
doing reviews or they won't be weekly
like they will be for these these this
first series they might just be
occasional every now and then basically
when i but i have a day that i don't
otherwise have a video will say but in
any case a quiet night in the second
episode of inside number nine with a
very neat gimmick which is that it is a
dialogue free episode
nobody really speaks it's not silent
there is the sound and the noise of what
is going on you hear you know things and
people and then you know there's
occasionally a little you know noises
like that and or somebody turns on a TV
there's that there's music so you know
there's all that stuff but there's no
dialogue pretty much and that's an
interesting gimmick so it's as far as
story goes it is the story of an attempt
at a art heist
of the piece of Modern Art from the home
of some wealthy guy or other you have
these these two burglars who don't seem
to be exceptionally good at what they're
doing and they you know they break in
and they're having to they're not only
trying to get this painting but they are
working around the guy who lives there
who owns the painting a member of the
household staff I guess she's the cook
or they she might be all-purpose because
she picks up stuff and does laundry just
I guess cook and maid and then there is
a young woman that initially who she is
in the nature of her relationship with
this other guy who's significantly older
than her isn't altogether clear but
there's basically three people in this
house that these burglars are constantly
trying to avoid crossing the high line
of avoid making enough noise that they
alert these people while trying to get
this painting and get it out so it is
this one is more flat-out comedic than
sardines was the previous episode and
even though it does get a little dark at
a couple of points it's it's it's a very
slapstick form of dark it doesn't it
doesn't leave you or at least me it
doesn't leave you unsettled the way that
sardines did and it's not bad I'm really
glad it wasn't the first episode because
I would have been pretty underwhelmed I
think there's a couple of things working
against this the first thing which is
not the fault of this show but I think
says a lot about the nature of its
overall premise for this episode it bore
more than a passing resemblance to a
short play I wrote in seventh grade
That's not me implying that they stole
my seventh grade piece of crap comedy
about people breaking in to try and
steal something and ever
thing goes wrong but a lot of the beats
a lot of the complications a lot of the
things that happen Bora surprisingly
close resemble as to that the reason I
mentioned that is I feel like that sort
of the writing level of this episode
it's a very juvenile you know idea of
what you know oh and then this oh and
then this oh and then this it a juvenile
is not really the right word that
implies a style of humour that is maybe
a little more crass than this is but
this does have its crass moments and I
think here's the thing if it wasn't for
the gimmick this really has almost
nothing going for it
what it's doing is very bog-standard
both in terms of concept and and the
progression of all of it it's just sort
of your standard everything goes wrong
in the course of a crime scenario so the
only thing that makes it unique is the
gimmick of no dialogue and gimmicks are
a funny thing because a gimmick a
properly applied gimmick to a story
that's already good can make a good
story
great I might go to example that will
always be momento momento had a story
that was already interesting that was
already one that was worth telling and
then the nature of the narrative in the
order that scenes were put in is a
gimmick that makes it better however
when a gimmick is applied to something
that has nothing else going for all it
does is make a mediocre thing pretty
good and that's basically what happens
here it turns a mediocre story into a
pretty good one but it can't be more
than that because you remove the gimmick
and like what is there to recommend
about this episode not a heck of a lot
if I'm being totally honest I think what
is impressive about this episode is the
execution of it
the pacing of it honestly it it's
difficult to properly pace out something
that you can't section off into dialogue
moments but you know to keep it
continually moving and figure out how
long this actions gonna take and get it
all down to a really tight 30-minute
runtime but not have it feel like you're
treading wheels like even though I said
none of what goes on is particularly
surprising or inventive it doesn't spin
wheels it doesn't time-fill nor does it
make any weird sort of leaps as far as
the pacing goes where suddenly things
are piling up faster than you know feels
earned so it's it is a well executed
gimmick slapped on to just a
bog-standard kind of story
and there are there are some of the
specifics that I that I people who know
me on this channel probably figured I
was gonna talk about and this is gonna
get into spoilers so that's my overall
thoughts on the episode it's not bad
it's fine depending on your own level of
appreciation for sort of the silent
comedy or slapstick or you know heist
gone wrong traditions and tropes you may
enjoy significantly more than I did but
for me it was just fine I would never
watch this episode again so that's it
spoiler free let's get into spoilers now
before I get into the big one that I
think a lot of people anyone who knows
me is expecting me to talk about let's
first of all talk about where this show
first lost me and that's when they
killed the dog let me put it this way as
soon as they killed that dog my first
thought was both these guys especially
the one with the mustache they both
better die cuz I don't know about
anybody else but with me when you kill a
dog no no I you you need to die now so
I'm glad that they did now the thing
that folks are probably expecting me to
talk about
has to do with the quote-unquote young
woman who appears and I was a lousy toss
of a hat but the reveal that she is
biologically and physically still very
much a man is a beat I don't care for
for a number of reasons
and on the are given that you know how
many fewer people watch this then watch
most of my other stuff I can't imagine
this would be the case but just
something off chanced the reason I let
my hair down to talk about this I have a
fluid sense of gender so I do I do care
about this kind of representation when
it shows up in these things so here are
my problems with this reveal the big one
well actually you know what back up
before I explain why this doesn't work I
don't automatically have a problem with
the reveal of someone appearing to be a
woman being revealed to be a man in
things I don't even automatically have a
problem with that being played for
comedy but the thing about any piece of
comedy about any joke is you have to
break to figure out at least for me from
my perspective because I don't do a lot
of blanket automatic this is always
offensive what makes something offensive
or not you have to break down what is it
or more importantly in a case like this
who is it that we are actually being
called to laugh at at whose expense is
this joke and the reason I don't like it
here is that ultimately it is no deeper
than hahaha hi it's really a guy and
we're just kind of invited to laugh
because that's funny
and there's a certain surprise value to
it and that could have been played off
well but the the peeing standing up
which actually first of all you know
huge cliched way to do that reveal but
additionally that I think that really
muddies the waters in a lot of ways and
in a way they probably didn't intend so
what I'm about to talk about now is me
totally over analyzing this I know I'm
about to do that I mean I know that what
I'm about to talk about I can almost
guarantee was stuff that they did not
think about so I am NOT I'm not calling
anybody you know a bigot or not an ally
or anything but I'm still gonna say this
so that whole thing with the taking the
week off and the peeing standing up that
creates a bigger problem because
initially the reveal I when the wig hit
the floor I did admittedly chuckle
because suddenly a couple of things
clicked into place because the the hair
was very obviously a wig and you know
she was pretty dang tall and her breasts
seemed oddly protruding like they were
not a natural progression of curves for
out of something jutting out because
they shouldn't have been there but I say
shouldn't like they were artificial it
was more my point so you know things
kind of clicked into place on the
initial reveal but then with the being
standing up and then when I looked up
the actress because it is an actress
she's actually I didn't recognize her
but she's from Game of Thrones you might
remember her from from the red wedding
as the pregnant woman who got stabbed in
the stomach ah so she's playing this
character now normally this is something
I actually didn't talk about
specifically when I did talk about
LGBTQ representation and casting in
regards to trans insist people but
something that I have mentioned more
than a few times in the comics comics
comments is that if a transgender
character is going to be played by a
cisgender actor which I don't like but
if it's going to happen it is better if
the gender of the cysts actor matches
the gender identity of the trans
character in other words if it is a
trans woman and it's going to be played
by sis actor it should be played by
assist woman or other than a sis man
because if you cast a sis man to play a
trans woman or a syst woman to play a
trans man then you are reinforcing the
idea that while they're just playing
dress up anyway and if they're really
just a man in a dress or they're really
just a woman in a suit at the end of the
day which is a very at best
uncomfortable impolite and also often at
times dangerous sentiment because it's
very much used to keep a population down
and belittle them and D legitimize their
lives and their experiences now you
would think based on all that that I
would be on oh well at least they have a
woman playing this part except I'm not
because between the peeing standing up
and the the getting rid of the wig this
doesn't read as a transgender character
to me now we don't know definitively we
don't get full context but speaking from
my own experience and my experiences of
people who I know and I've talked to
this seems a lot more like a non
transitioning transvestite or
crossdresser and I say that specifically
when it comes to something like the
peeing standing up because again I'm
sure that decision was made simply for
the sake of the joke but if you are full
if if you are a trans woman which again
to be clear I'm not but as a general
rule if you are a trans woman a big
fundamental part
of that is dysphoria in regards to your
body specifically in regards to your
sexual organs in other words you kinda
hate your penis and as a result
generally a trans woman is gonna sit
down to pee
if only because it draws less attention
to them for themselves to the fact that
they have a penis they don't have to
look at it they don't have to aim it
they just sit down and feel more like a
woman
so at that moment again I'm sure played
for joke means that I don't read this as
a trans woman which makes the casting of
a sis woman very odd to me and not fall
under the sort of thing that I explained
before about lending some credence to
the gender identity of a trans character
because I don't think this actually is a
transgender character and the final
thing that I'll note on this I think the
thing that really kind of turned me
against the episode as a whole in
particularly this particular aspect is
when the burglar rolls under the bed to
hide and there is an inflatable sex doll
with breasts and a dick and I hated that
because you know we've already had a
moment that is little more than hahaha
man and a wig man in a dress and now on
top of that we're gonna go and yeah
aren't these kind of folks always these
crazy sexual deviants because that has
no bearing on the plot like none it has
no bearing on the characters there's no
bearing on the part the idea that these
people are kinky at all has nothing to
do with anything
it does matter that they have affection
for each other because that is plot
relevant that is affecting actions and
affecting decisions this is just a cheap
lousy gag that associates sexual
deviancy with gender nonconformity and I
am NOT always gonna say that's
unacceptable but you need to ask
yourself why am i doing that and if
you're not doing that for anything
more than a cheap laughs which is what
that was please don't do it
so that is emitted Lee another part of
what I didn't love about this episode
but again to be fair it was well
executed it was a well executed gimmick
episode but I don't think that what it
was and what it was doing was
particularly unique or inventive or
original outside of the gimmick nor do I
you know have no issues with the story
itself because I do I have some
significant issues I will say I did
enjoy the sort of cuz I mean how many
times have we had the commentary on
modern art where it's like oh god you
know anybody could make that that's
worth money what that again very tired
but I do like the way that they approach
that other than because they couldn't
have characters say it so instead they
illustrate it by the fact that these
guys take this painting out of the out
of the frame and then recreate it with
paper towels and tin foil well enough
that another thief who comes in and
kills them yes they deserved it for
killing the dog comes in and kills them
and steals the painting and does not
even for a second
flinch at the fact that he's just
grabbed a bunch of paper towels and
tinfoil and even someone who has seen
this painting numerous times before kind
of only gives it like a half passing
second glance and then moves on I kind
of like the again the delivery of what
is a fairly tight joke modern art isn't
it nuts but the delivery of that was
well done kind of like how the gimmick
is a decent delivery of a not especially
original story so that's it for this
particular episode of inside number nine
have you seen it what did you think
about it don't tell me i overanalyze I
know I did I acknowledge that but
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it
all the stuff to do I am gonna recommend
you follow me on Twitter and or Facebook
because I alert you of new videos every
time they go up there if all you're
doing is subscribing to this channel
there is a fairly good chance that if
you aren't already you may soon not be
getting my videos in your subscription
feed you too is screwing with a lot of
people so if you want to get you know be
able to keep up but I would really
recommend trusting something other than
just your subscription feed so Facebook
Twitter patreon hey
those would be the main ones that I do
updates on every single time there is a
new video here so there's links to those
and a bunch of other stuff down in the
description and this folks you are the
council I just run the meetings and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]